the head coach of Nevada basketball Eric
Musselman here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you coach great rich thanks so
much for having me on you bet thanks for
joining so where do we start first the
game or your your postgame celebration
which which one have you heard about
which one have you heard about more rich
it depends which way you want this
conversation to go we can I'm open to
talking about either one cuz I mean this
is just such an unbelievable sporting
event to be a part of March Madness
you know it's like nothing that I've
ever been a part of and having coached
in the NBA nothing compares to you know
to being a part of this one-and-done
format and crazy stuff happens and I'm
having so much fun you know it's kind of
like a second career for me and I feel
so lucky and fortunate to have this
opportunity and and we're excited we
can't wait to get to Atlanta yeah I bet
so let's talk about this game what do
you say to your team when you're down 22
and half half the half after halftime is
gone what do you say here's what I think
the big thing rich was if we go back to
last year we had a game in Albuquerque
New Mexico and we were down like 26
points and if we were down I don't even
know what it was with like 11 minutes to
go it was like 24 or something we came
back and won that game in overtime so
some of the coaches some of the players
we had been a part of that we did bring
that up that we felt like we could we
could make another comeback and what we
tried to do is just give the players
many goals we kept saying hey every 4
minute timeout we got to cut this thing
because I think it was 22 points down
with 11 minutes to go or 1058 on the
clock and so it was how do we get this
thing down to 18 and then how do we get
it down to 15 and then how do we get
into single digits and once we got it in
and sing single digits you could tell
the the entire atmosphere in the arena
the momentum completely shifted it
shifted with the fans that shifted with
everybody and and at that point now our
guys are playing off adrenaline and the
most amazing thing about the whole game
is
we only had two turnovers against a team
that's arguably one of the top two
defensive teams in the country and a
very physical defensive team and then
you add in the fact that our starting
point guard of three years Lindsey drew
whose father just has taken over the
Cavs right now he blew his Achilles out
five games ago and what we had to do
rich is we moved our power forward to
our point guard position
and so just us valuing the ball and
getting shots on goal to me was the most
amazing thing of all that happened last
night and then you got the Martin Martin
kids they're really special man I mean
so what do they do do you think that is
going to be difficult for forget about
Loyola Chicago but perhaps Kentucky and
I know you know Coach Cal for a while I
want to get into that in a second but
what what do you think they can do that
can help you cut down more nets here you
know Cody Martin is the power forward
that I'm referring to that that's now
playing the point he's kind of a
jack-of-all-trades for us rich he's you
know I I refer to him there's like a
utility infielder but he's a superstar
you know he's a guy that can play
shortstop third base second base
go to the outfield if you need him he
plays all over the floor the one
adjustment that we made defensively is
we took him off of Cincinnati's star
power forward and we put him on there
off guard Evans who is absolutely
killing us so he's not only our point
guard now he's one of our best
rebounders he's one of our best assist
guys he's he does everything for us and
then his brother caleb is a phenomenal
scorer he can really really change the
complexion of his game with this
three-point shooting and and the the
neat thing about both Martin kids is
they're such high character kids and
they absolutely unequivocally hate to
lose Eric Musselman here on the Rich
Eisen show the head coach of Nevada
basketball here on the show what's your
first basketball Mehrer memory Eric
I guess my first basketball memory is
when my father was coaching at Ashland
college in Ohio and I would just go to
practice with him and and hang out and
you know he had a bold pregame warmup
that was like no other where guys were
spinning balls and people were on
unicycles and the gym was rocking and
then he went from Ashland to the
University of Minnesota and I would say
that you know I'd leave Italy remember
going to school in Bloomington Minnesota
and then after school asking my mom
please take me down to Williams Arena so
that I could go hang out and I you know
originally I thought I would go watch
the three o'clock practice it would end
at 5:00 and at that time there was not
time limits on practice and practice
really went from about three to seven
and then my dad would watch film and I'd
get home at 10:30 as a fourth grader but
I want I wanted to do it day after day
after day and my dad was my idol and and
I wanted to follow in his footsteps and
since the day that I can remember and
then I mean just your stops from Rapid
City to you know the NBA Orlando in
Atlanta's assistant you you had two
years with the Golden State Warriors the
Memphis Grizzlies Kings this is your not
your first rodeo in Reno I mean we can
go on and on and on here but the reason
why I bring this up is that you know
here you are in 2018 with this moment
and I'd love to just let fans understand
what it's like to be a lifer and and go
on this basketball journey and be able
to enjoy it the way that you have here
coach well yeah I mean I've obviously
rich people you know I think people see
you know last night you know how excited
I was after the game and and how excited
I am in the locker room and with my you
know my players and to me it's just been
an incredible journey I mean I got a
great opportunity to be a head coach at
a really young age of two teams made a
career decision when I got let go by the
Kings that I wanted to be a dad I had
two sons that I you know felt like I
hadn't been around them
enough so I was dadad for three years I
sat in carpool lane sipping a Starbucks
coffee and one day while I was in
carpool lane I you know after three
years I said I got I got to get back to
coaching and I went to the d-league and
did that for two years and and didn't
get an NBA call-up so to speak as a
coach and we had two really really great
d-league seasons and I made a decision
to go into college basketball and I knew
what I didn't know and and I had to put
my ego aside I had to ask for my
family's blessing to go be in a college
assistant spent two years at Arizona
State then a year at LSU and really rich
the Year at LSU was a defining moment
because Flip Saunders had called and
flip it played for my dad and and he had
offered me a job with the Timberwolves
and when I passed that up to go to LSU
and work for Johnny Jones who was
someone that I had no prior relationship
you know my family was all in on the
college experience and I'm so glad I did
it and so really the three years of
being an assistant let me have time to
sit back and and and and look at the
recruiting landscape and to try to come
up with a game plan when I was lucky or
fortunate enough to get a head job a
couple more minutes here left with Eric
Musselman the HC of Nevada basketball
prior to taking on Loyola of Chicago
after bouncing Texas and cincinnati here
on the Rich Eisen show and and then you
know obviously we're seeing you at us as
a seven seed Loyola is one of two eleven
seeds do you think the Blue Bloods if
you will and the smaller programs again
if you will are getting closer together
in college basketball and if so why I
really do rich I think I think there's
parity I think when you look at eight
hundred and eight hundred plus transfers
a year
I mean I'm 53 years old and in 1987 when
I was a senior my four years in college
I can remember maybe three guys in the
whole conference that that I played in
in the WCC to transfer I don't even know
if there was three and now what you're
seeing
800-plus and so guys are going from
power schools to mid-majors tulo majors
guys are going from low majors up and so
you're seeing this transition and it's
not just college I mean guys are playing
for for AAU teams guys are going to four
and five different high schools and it's
kind of the the society that we live in
and I think because of all the changing
rosters it has brought parity to the
college game no I know I know you don't
want to overlook the over the windshield
here but you know there's coach Cal the
five seed you you know him correct you
you have a history with him with Coach
Cal I was coaching the Venezuelan
national I mean the Dominican Republic
national team and and Coach Cal called
me one day and he said hey mus can you
send me some tape and and can you do a
little write-up on the Dominican players
I said what are you talking about Cal
why do you need that he said well I'm
the new coach of the Dominican Republic
I said hold on I I got a contract in my
email no no I don't know maybe they
haven't told you so Cal ended up
coaching the team after I had been there
the prior year and I ended up going to
Venezuela we played against each other
but he's a great friend when I was out
of coaching you know he was a guy that I
could call and ask for advice and it's
it's funny because we were actually
texting each other last night and he's a
guy that I certainly have really really
looked up to especially since I've been
in the college game alright last one for
you let's get to it now coach now I know
that you were caught with your shirt off
last year just putting on a championship
t-shirt I understand if you're just
gonna change out of a dress shirt into a
championship t-shirt on the court but
well what what was the idea behind just
you know taking the shirt off going in
the locker room I had been tipped off
not that there was gonna be a lot of
water sprayed okay in my direction I had
a really expensive shirt on that I
didn't want and I had a good tie and I
work out every day because I got a
really very very beautiful wife and so I
have no problem taking my shirt off with
a camera around
okay no III hear you who was the player
who signed your chest who's that
actually my it was my son my son Matthew
muscleman was in the locker room with me
and he's a high school junior and one of
the players was good and he grabbed the
pen and I guess he might have wanted
some air time he signed your chest okay
so now what I mean is this now gonna
become a thing if you beat loyal or is
this gonna be you're gonna go and start
doing other going to go full
Chippendales here nope that's it I think
I got a I got a try to uphold a little
bit of professionalism and I'm gonna try
to keep my shirt on ice for the
remainder of the season okay hey
congrats on going from venti macchiatos
- venti wins in the in the tournament
coach look forward to the next time
already there's a coach Eric Musselman
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience